your story is you're a black lives
matter activist cast onto a reality show
started doing your research for the show
and then debunked yourself and now what
you consider yourself conservative I
guess yeah I'd say conservative I have
some things I lean libertarian on but
overall it's a conservative so how did
this happen what is this
so basically it was in 2020 I was in the
process for the show already when
everything happened with George Floyd
and then after that they started wanting
even more footage of just the things
that I was working on as far as being a
BLM activist because I was doing it
before it even blew up so in that
process I found a Candace Owens video
actually on accident and I was so mad at
what she said because she said only in
the black community do we take our
lowest common denominator and make that
the Forefront of our community so I was
so enraged by that because I thought
about it and I'm like she's pretty much
right so I started listing out like
different prageru videos I found because
she was working heavily with prageru at
the time and I just tried to debunk
everything I was leaning towards being a
socialist even at that time too so with
socialism with CRT with cultural
appropriation just one by one I'm
watching these five minute videos on
prageru.com or I'm watching Candace
Owens videos and I just realized wow
I've been lied to about everything my
entire perspective growing up black and
feeling like I had to root my identity
and my blackness was really just a a
sham and it was taught to me for
strategic purposes it's what I look back
at it as
so so what was what were some of the
stuffs you were working on as a BLM
activist like what were you doing
um so I was online advocating a lot like
I wasn't like a huge name as a BLM
activist but I was definitely helping
organize some local events I was always
posting on Instagram about oh like this
is racist this is what a microaggression
is like pretty much teaching people to
look at every single thing as racist and
when I look back at those old videos and
clips that I had I just cringe oh man
there's nothing the left organizes so
much better oh yeah yeah just infinitely
better but it was like it was mainstream
and popular so it was easy I'd imagine
right like you turn on the news and
they're telling you exactly what you
want to hear well 2020 it was it
definitely was in 2020 before that it
was still was people were leaning
towards my direction or they couldn't
tell me I was wrong because they still
even before George Floyd didn't want to
be called racist but at the time yeah I
hadn't I didn't have much pushback and I
would have conversations with
conservatives and people on the other
side of the aisle and it was interesting
that I didn't get the hatred that I now
received being on the other side like
being a conservative and try to have
these exact same conversations with
liberals they don't want to talk to me
or if they do talk to me it's such an
angry conversation that's so based in
emotion that it's so hard to get logic
into the conversation so you're watching
these Candace Owens video you mentioned
that uh
she made the argument that the black
community how did you find how did you
describe it uh yeah we take the lowest
common denominator and make that the
Forefront of our community you still see
that today look at people like cardi B
putting put on the pedestal that she's
on that's terrifying you have a stripper
who notoriously was struggling men and
robbing them and doing all these
different things and guess who decides
to interview her Joe Biden Joe Biden
wants to give her a platform because
that's how he feels that he can reach
the Black and Hispanic communities and
that's very telling on how the left
views people of color that he went and
got someone that was borderline
illiterate to be the person to convey
his different talking points I do think
it's fair to point out though
I I think everybody elevates the lowest
common denominator because it sells but
that being said I mean if you compare
cardi B and Joe Biden Joe Biden is
corrupt and crooked and represents like
the worst of American political
political class as is Hillary Clinton
and then here he is sitting with cardi B
I mean I think and there's I like cardi
B more than Joe Biden I mean hasn't she
come out and said some stuff that's
actually fairly based she did call out
the Dalai Lama for the weird stuff about
yeah she did she did she did say that
that was weird so she's got that going
for her she's had a couple different
things and she like call out inflation
inflation she's like my grocery bill has
gone up by like 500 yeah I think she
might just be like
I think the issue is not so much cardi B
but you're right in the elevation of
like what lowest common denominator
stuff or I should say Candace Owens was
right so when you heard that that pissed
you off because you didn't believe it or
what it did because then I started
thinking specifically about George Floyd
at the time and when you look at back at
his character and the kind of person he
was and even just the tragedy of what
happened to him when you look back at
all of that what about him was worth
putting him on murals putting him on all
these buildings when you drive through
these cities people have tattoos of
George Floyd there's probably going to
be streets named after him if there
aren't already it's creepy I'm from
Minnesota so I'm from that area right
and it's it's weird too because you
think about it and I'm like if you get a
tattoo of somebody like that if you
haven't at least done a cursory look
into like their social media history
like you are owned by the media like if
you if you're going to get somebody
tattooed on you or you're going to
evangelize someone to that level right
you should at the very least have a
general understanding you could make the
argument that look I'm not tattooing him
I'm tattooing what his death represents
you could make that argument I still
think it's a bad argument it's weird but
you should at least look into what
they're doing most people aren't they
just they don't realize it and they're
not looking any deeper into it were you
were you weren't religious I'd imagine
then were you I am you were I always
have been yeah back then it wasn't as
like devout as it is now it's definitely
grown in the last couple years you start
to learn stuff yeah I only asked because
there was that mural of George Floyd on
the wall that got struck by lightning
and it was just the George Floyd part
and I'm just like dude that I don't know
man God that's so good I don't know I
don't know if I don't I I'm not going to
prescribe good bad or whatever it just
happened like I I I I just love getting
an opportunity to talk about this
happening there was a building they
painted this big mirror on the whole
wall right in the middle was George
Floyd and for some reason lightning
struck the wall and blew up the brick
portion with just George Floyd on it and
I'm just I'm just Freedom people have to
stop playing with God God's not here to
play that's crazy I mean fall Idols or
whatever you want to call it but I mean
to the point where people are tattooing
George Floyd on themselves and yeah look
man it's like we can we can lament
criminal justice and degradation of
culture we can lament this dude was
doing was chewing on a speed ball or
whatever we can we can say It's
upsetting that he died and all that
stuff but to the point where people put
tattoos on their body of this guy they
build statues for him that's insane
I mean that's just crazy yeah but people
have done the same thing with Trayvon
Martin oh and all that stuff so that's
not going anywhere it's kind of what
happens when the media becomes yeah well
not that but the the media turns real
life people in real life tragedy into
celebrity because you don't know where
your television ends and where the
actual news story begins so real life
people who have gone through real life
experiences whether good or bad are now
the idols of certain people especially
people that are very very aware of
what's going on in the news or think
they are I still don't think Trayvon
Martin was the best comparison to George
Floyd though even though it's all under
that BLM umbrella like there were
similarities like you started yeah of
course
um back in 2008 I believe
um uh well it was later than that 12 12.
13 2014 I thought well 12 it was Mike no
yeah that was okay yeah I think it was
20 I think it was like 2013 or something
I'm not sure about Trayvon Mike Brown
was 2012. if I'm no no no my brown was
2014 I'm pretty sure
yeah but George Zimmerman the person who
killed Trayvon Martin didn't have any
type of
I guess just need to protect Society I
still feel like he's a pretty terrible
person George Zimmerman himself has a
really bad track record so I don't think
it's past comparable
um with like uh Derek Chauvin Michael
Brown would have been the better example
of the one yeah yeah that's yeah that's
that's the better example that I'm
thinking but those those people those
real life people have now been turned
into a form of celebrity that people
worship in whether you actually look
into it you have to do a lot of research
if you're actually going to look into
something like that well let me ask you
so you're you're this activist your
borderline socialist you start what
they're gonna have you on TV you start
watching these videos I imagine you you
quit the show or you didn't go to and be
like hey I got some things to say on
this show you know it was tough time
like I was mortified like everybody when
I tell the story now they just viewed
just like all the positive of it but you
have to think this is months of just
turmoil of all these different things
that I've believed in for so long being
exposed is just not legitimate but it
got to October and I was getting ready
to fly to London and I just had this
pow-wow with myself and like I can't do
this I don't stand for any of this
anymore so I called them and I just
pretty much told them it just wasn't for
me what are your friends and family
think
uh I didn't tell too many people I was
in the process actually because they
were pretty strict on the ndas
no I mean like uh when you started
discovering that a lot of the stuff you
thought was not true I imagine like you
go to your friend and you're like
I I have to imagine because I I've been
there where
I'm hanging out at my friend's house I'm
in California and they sit there like
hanging around like drinking coffee and
then one of them just says something
completely false and then it's like the
first thing I think is like oh
what do I do if I come you can't just
come out and be like you're wrong you
know what I mean they're not going to
take well to that they want to be an
authority on this political ideology
that's why they brought it up
yeah it was definitely interesting I had
a combination of everything a lot of my
friends kind of started to make the
journey with me becoming more
conservatives because they knew how
passionate I was about BLM and all the
liberalism I stood for so for me to look
at it and be like I don't know about
this anymore especially with everything
happening with covid and everyone's
trust in every institution starting to
be questioned a lot of people started to
just support me regardless of what it
was that I stood for on the other hand I
had people completely excommunicate me
including family members I have a
sibling I haven't spoken to in years wow
that come just deleted me off of
everything hasn't spoken to me and
I have friends who have done the same
thing but I don't even view them as real
friends I don't I don't believe that
actions like that are related to like I
think that's evidence to the fact they
know you're right they to a certain
degree that you're right they're driven
by social acceptance not by Factor logic
and so they're like you threaten their
attempts to fit in so they have to
remove you because we don't do that like
the right tends not to do that I say
tends not to because you know it's not
absolute but the the libertarian former
liberal types the conservative types are
constantly trying to tell people like
here's what I think and why and the left
is just more like I don't want you to
say what you think you shouldn't be
allowed yeah I'd say that's really
really prominent in the black community
uh the black community has a tendency to
put each other in a box and if the
second you step out of that box or as
Candace Owen says escaping the
Democratic Plantation it's a huge issue
just as far as the music you're allowed
to like the clothes you're supposed to
wear the culture the way you talk the
way that if you speak too eloquently
you're insulted in a lot of areas in the
black community we're even told like I
remember being a kid I'm in this area
full of Agriculture and I was bullied by
my family because I was going to take an
FFA class they talked me out of doing it
they're like you're black you can't be
in an agriculture class which is so
wrong to begin with for so many reasons
but black people tend to put the
shackles on our own feet and I keep
telling people within the community and
outside the community that you have to
stop allowing yourself to be forced into
a category you have to be able to look
at the bigger picture of the world and
just identify who you actually are
rather than be told who you are because
your skin color man
so you made it though huh Prager you
hired you I made it he's been good to me
and that takes a lot of Courage though
like to to walk away from a support
system like that in a lot of ways those
are the people that are structurally the
most supportive to your upbringing in a
lot of ways right like it's got to be
very very difficult to walk away from
people that have been that instrumental
in getting to you you know being a part
of your life up until that point yeah I
just have to change my mentality I
didn't walk away from them they walked
away from me no since it like yeah so
you have to you have to accept when
they're going to walk away from you yeah
of course uh it's just one of those
things I realize that if I'm not willing
to stand on truth and integrity then
what is it that I actually represent
because if you don't stand for anything
you fall for everything right and I just
want to be able to look myself in the
mirror if I continue to advocate for
these things just because I'm told to
rather than recognizing the research
that I've done and going out and being
like you know what this is actually the
truth I was wrong so many people are
afraid just to get online and admit that
they're wrong or even just person to
person but humility is one of the
greatest things that you can possibly
have and the media likes to shame doing
your own own research now you're not
supposed to do your own research anymore
it's very dangerous that's crazy it's
very dangerous we had a Winston Marshall
from Mumford and Sons on that last week
and he so his story is he reads books
and he had like no followers but I mean
Mumford and Sons is a huge band no joke
look at their discography it's like
their first album hit number two
billboard then every other album was
number one when it released they were
huge and so he tweets out like just read
Andy knows book very great good work
Andy no and they attacked him for it he
basically is forced to issue an apology
and then I mean this dude's amazing
shout out to to this guy he's there's a
reason why his he was part of a band
that Rose to the top he said he didn't
want to live the LIE he couldn't live
with himself knowing that he put this
fake apology he thought to himself what
am I going to do go to all my friends
and family and say I don't I I I believe
this thing I don't actually believe I
can't do it so so he was like he decided
you know what fine
to preserve to save his band mates from
this this Trauma from this or from this
Scandal and controversy in crisis he's
going to leave the band and then he's
going to come out publicly retract his
apology and say here's what I really
think so they went after him he thought
about and said nah he would rather be
true to himself with all of the anger
and hate around him than to live a lie I
I imagine that's it felt like kind of
what you were conveying to yeah for sure
I have so much respect for that and I
always tell people like to an extent you
have to prioritize your piece so if you
are not willing to be outspoken about
everything that you believe in at least
be willing to stand firm and stand
against the things that you don't
believe in yeah like especially with
things like when you're seeing all the
kids going to drag shows you don't have
to necessarily go out and just say like
everything about your conservative
values but you at least have to look at
something as foul as little children
being in a drag show and being able to
say you know what we need to stop this
there has to be some level of pushback
but it isn't I mean I have to imagine
that there I'll put it this way there's
tropes about the the black community
actually being fairly conservative right
oh yeah not like they the left would
call it homophobic call whatever you
want so I have to imagine this stuff
doesn't go over well
oh it doesn't it doesn't at all I've
been saying that for so long a lot of
black people now and this goes for
pretty much every ethnicity especially
Hispanic and Asian communities where
there are so many conservative values
that are just instilled in these
minority groups as families but they
still continue to vote Democratic
because they're told to because if you
ask so many of these people in these
communities why is it that you vote with
democratics like that's what I was told
to do as a kid yeah that's what my whole
family does I mean I was sold too I I
remember going with my family and I'm
told like so what just Democrat all the
way down I'm like okay I guess they have
done such a amazing job of branding the
right as inherently racist but not just
that as somehow the party of money even
though all evidence points to the
contrary now that big business votes uh
goes to the left now all of the
corporations are behind leftist values
but when you read these articles from
these Outlets they talk about the right
being the party of of uh money and
privilege and all the evidence points to
the contrary but it doesn't matter
because like you said a lot of them
aren't going to do the research
necessary to actually go out and figure
that out have you have you had a chance
to talk with Candace Owens about all
this briefly I met her once it was like
a really quick passing by but we've
messed each other a few times she's been
super supportive of me yeah I imagine
that would be one heck of a conversation
to be honest oh yeah I can't wait to the
time I get to just sit down and really
pick her brain on things what's funny
about what you said about trying to
debunk the prageru five minute videos
those would be the hardest ones to
debunk because it's literally a lot of
them are just listed facts about it
would be like impossible to go through
that you'd have to literally if they
were lying they'd be the like the most
lies you've ever seen in a row because
most of them are just those are like a
lot of my favorite videos that they did
back well I I recently just did uh I did
two Prager u5 and I think I don't know
if they're both out yet maybe one of
them but it was like specific references
to things that happened and like the the
summary of the video is based on like
here's the thing that happened here's
the media said here's what the
government responded with I think we
talked about Mike Brown Michael Brown
and how the activist said hands up don't
shoot but then Obama's justice
department said actually that's not true
so it's Whose Line Obama or the activist
Eric Holder the AG and Obama was the
president they investigated and found
that it that Michael Brown was not did
not have his hands up so I mean it's
clear that it was not uh uh that Michael
Brandon didn't Michael Brown did not
have his hands up it was that was alive
from him what's day one thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time